[Musique]
Cyril Melchior président du Département
a reçu ce mercredi 30 août le nouveau
ministre des Outre-mer Philippe Vigier
nous avons évoqué des sujets qui
concernent bien évidemment la vie
quotidienne des Réunionnaises et des
Réunionnais on a parlé des sujets qui
touchent à l'enfance en difficulté en
danger on a surtout parlé aussi de des
dossiers qui concernent les personnes
âgées le bienvier hier à La Réunion et
tout ce qui concerne le développement de
l'île son aménagement à travers le
basculement des eaux le transfert des
eaux d'inston os nous avons évoqué aussi
des sujets du mal logement et notre
souhait c'est de faire en sorte que
toutes celles et ceux qui vivent dans la
précarité dans des logements insalubs
voient leur habitat amélioré
il y a une convention qui va être passée
entre le Conseil départemental entre
l'Agence nationale d'amélioration de
l'habitat et l'État au travers d'un
anagramme un peu compliqué un acronyme
s'appelle LBU donc ne retenez pas ça
simplement retenez que c'est 70 millions
d'euros cette convention elle doit être
prête à la fin de l'année 2023 c'est pas
dans deux ans fin 2023 ça sera un outil
merveilleux pour que l'on puisse
ensemble Département et l'État avoir les
outils les plus simples les plus
annonces contre le 15 et 30 novembre je
recevrai tous les présidents d'exécutif
de tous les territoires ultramarins
avec tous les ministres en intervie
ministériel territoire par territoire et
on regardera mesures par mesure où on en
est on corrigera les trajectoires là où
ça va pas on les accélèrera s'il le faut
il m'a donné plus dans de la République
c'est d'agir vite d'agir fort mais
d'agir surtout à l'écoute et en lien
avec les acteurs du territoire et en
particulier les départements le
lendemain le ministre des autres mères a
été reçu au Musée historique de Villèle
il a pu visiter l'ancien domaine de la
famille pamont des bassins et observer
les fouilles archéologiques qui sont
actuellement menées
Philippe Vigier également pu découvrir
le projet de réhabilitation et de
transformation du site en musée de
l'habitation et de l'esclavage qui sera
achevée en 2026
que je viens de voir
vous avez utilisé tout à l'heure
des mots très fort
d'ailleurs vous avez bien fait de dire
on devrait plutôt célébrer la fin de
l'esclavage et avec ce musée Bidel
propriété du département avec ce projet
d'envergure en fait qui intègre toutes
les dimensions
il intègre naturellement de la dimension
patrimoniale
et j'étais également très impressionné
je vois la mettre de la voix qui arrive
par tout à l'heure la démonstration que
nous a faite de la conception de ce
projet la maquette que j'ai pu voir tout
à l'heure elle est inspirante un peu
comme ce département de La Réunion qui
est inspirant
pour toute l'équipe que j'ai pu voir
jusqu'à présent pour son troisième jour
de visite sur Lille Philippe Vigier a pu
découvrir l'extraordinaire biodiversité
que Russell la forêt départementale
automaniale de la réunion le président
du Département l'a accompagné au Mac où
il a pu lui présenter le plan un million
d'arbres pour la Réunion qui vise à
lancer une démarche de reconquête
écologique sur toute l'île
depuis le 18e siècle
571 espèces végétale ont disparu de la
terre et chaque année trois espèces
trois nouvelles espèces disparaissent
donc ce mouvement perpétuel de
disparition des espèces végétales nous
interpellent c'est pour cela que nous
avons mis en place le plan 1 million
d'arbres qui vise à
regénérer des espaces
devenus presque désertique au fil des
années des espaces qui ont été
endommagés par les activités humaines et
aujourd'hui tout le monde l'a dit nous
disposons d'une richesse
endémique qu'il nous faut protéger
préserver et mais aussi amplifier dans
tout le patrimoine les ministres ensuite
pris la direction de l'observatoire
astronomique toujours au max pour la
signature d'une convention autour du
fond vert pour la restauration des
milieux naturels
[Musique]